- Whenever you're ready.
- [Mark] All right, Latoya, how are you?
- Good.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Did the talk we had
last time helped you at all?
- [Latoya] A little bit, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Have you talked
about that stuff before
with anyone?
- [Latoya] No, never.
- [Mark] Never.
- [Latoya] Now it's all over YouTube.
- [Mark] Now the whole
world knows your story.
- Well that's good, I like that.
I feel better, I let it out.
- [Mark] Yeah I think it's healthy to
- Yeah, than to hold it in.
It's better to let that
stuff out, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
So,
How do you feel about
the life you're living,
you're down here...
- Now?
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you were short changed?
Do you feel like you were...
- Yeah, I was.
I was short changed a whole lot.
- [Mark] I mean like of all
of the stories on my channel,
you know people want to help so-and-so,
they want to help this
person, that person.
But to me, your story keeps
coming back to my head.
And saying like,
Jesus, if anyone got
robbed of their childhood,
of their life...
Me,
I had no childhood.
- [Mark] I mean, what was the
happiest moment of your life?
- When I turned 13,
- [Mark] And what happened?
- And I ran away from home.
- [Mark] That was the
happiest moment of your life?
- Man, I felt like a caged animal.
Like an animal locked in
and then you let it out,
it goes buck wild.
I was locked in so much
that when I got out,
I went buck wild.
So I was having sex and all that.
But, my step-dad raped me at six years old
so I don't have sex before then.
But on my own, I'm so happy.
Got out of house like a caged animal.
I got buck wild everywhere.
Here, there, everywhere, like,
and didn't go home,
I was just buck wild.
Ain't nothing to do, I was a caged animal.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] And at that age
what where you doing?
- Fuckin' and suckin' and,
doing everything.
I was just happy, like,
I was just doing everything. Buck wild!
I was in the house all the time
(indistinguishable speech)
My sister and brother would do shit wrong
and I would get blamed for
it 'cause I'm the oldest.
You know?
So I got buck wild, I was like
(claps hands)
outta there.
I was happy, I was gone.
Like a freeway, I was outta there.
605 freeway.
- [Mark] And now you're how old?
- 39
- [Mark] 39.
- Be 40 September 1st.
- [Mark] And where do you-
I mean, do you feel like this
is a low point for you, or?
How do you feel your life is going?
(police sirens)
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Cause like I said before,
this was not a life I want it to be.
A husband, two car garage,
a house, kids, you know?
Like that.
- [Mark] So you're living a
life that's very, very different
from what you...
- Yeah but it ain't my fault though.
I ain't ask to be born.
My auntie, she,
(sigh)
she used to stick her finger in my butt.
You know, my auntie?
Two fingers in my butt.
When I was a kid,
I didn't get nothing.
Drink beer in my bottle,
I don't get nothing.
I was treated like shit my whole life
and I don't deserve that.
I'm a good person.
A good mom, a good wife,
I'll be, you know?
Why that whore, my mom had all these men
in and out the house?
I said it before, seven different daddies.
I don't know.
Suckin' and fuckin', that's all I know.
From my mom, from my aunties, you know?
Telling me
- [Mark] It's like everyone
around you let you down?
- Yeah, but my grandmother,
my grandma, oh I miss,
my grandma didn't.
- [Mark] Except your grandmother?
- I love that lady, she didn't.
She had my back, she didn't doubt me.
She didn't put me down.
I tell my son she believed me.
My mom, when my third daddy
raped me, I told my mom.
You know what she said?
He always think that pussy the same.
He always- all the kids have that.
They all have the same pussy.
That's wrong.
- [Mark] He what?
He don't want that pussy, the same pussy.
He don't want it.
"He don't want the same pussy."
She said that, my mom.
After he raped me, she said,
"No, he don't want the same pussy."
Why'd you say your own daughter that?
At seven, six, seven years
old, eight years old?
So my grandma, she was the man.
She had my back.
I miss her so much.
Rosetta, she had my back.
- [Mark] What would make you happy today?
(indistinguishable speech)
- If I had an apartment,
my own place, not a tent.
You know, I'm happy in a box.
Anything but a tent.
I'm tired of living.
(Latoya crying)
It's not my fault.
I'm grown now but,
thing is that if something happened today,
brings back memories
from when I was a kid.
Like sitting in the car, and
you know, he'd have my breasts.
Reminds me of when I was a kid.
Shit like that,
just from my whole life.
It fucks me up.
I can't- they say you can't let the past
fuck your future up.
But not true.
It's not true.
In the past, they touch me on my breasts
it brings back memories of the past
from that time they touching my breasts.
That's not true.
They'll say it's in the past.
The past, you know,
whatever, the future,
they can't say that because it's not true.
The past do fuck your future up.
Past got a lot to do with
your future, you know?
I can't have no sex with them.
I can have sex, but I don't like that,
no one can touch me.
You can't do this, you can't do that.
Too many rules when I be
out there prostituting.
You know?
And you can't be having
no rules while somebody
out there payin' you to fuck 'em.
Yeah, I got fuckin' rules.
You can't touch my pussy.
You can't touch my titties.
Can't touch this.
You can't have no rules,
like you can't do that.
You can get hurt like that.
Killed like that.
People have paid their money
and then you're gonna say
can't touch me,
you can't do this,
you can't do that,
you know?
You get stabbed, raped
and killed like that
because of somebody like me
fucking it up for everybody
cause they can't touch my titties,
can't touch my pussy,
can't touch this,
can't touch that.
And they paid money already.
And then they want to
take their money back.
They want to fight.
I can't get mad at them.
It's me.
You know?
- [Mark] Is there anyone
around in your life
that you feel like they're not trying
to take advantage of you?
- Now?
Yeah, I don't let anybody take
advantage of me no more.
It's not going to happen no more.
I don't let anybody take advantage of me
or hurt me
or try and get a hold.
I don't let anybody do that.
I don't let anybody
close to me to do that.
You know, I'm-
It's like this.
All my life, I been treated
so bad, all my life.
So when a person good to me,
I don't know how to treat them.
I don't know how to treat people
because I've been treated bad all my life.
It's not fair.
It's not right.
I've been treated so bad all my life
to where if a person is good in my life,
I don't know how to treat them.
I'm only used to it people
treating me like shit.
So, if you're good to me, I
don't know how to treat you.
Oh wow, he's good to
me, I don't believe it.
You know?
It's like.
My auntie, my mom, my sister...
I don't know.
I never did anything wrong with my mom.
For Mother's Day,
I'd get her a gift every year.
For Mother's day,
for birthday every year,
you know?
And she still treated me like I'm a dog,
It wasn't right.
I wondered why.
I had no clue.
I told her one day,
"Mom, why do you always
treat me like shit?"
"Why do you treat me like this?"
I still don't know why.
I was a good daughter.
You know, I went to school.
I did everything I had to do.
I didn't do anything wrong.
I did something wrong,
but not, like, to be treated like
I was treated, you know?
I wouldn't treat a dog like that.
One kicked me in my stomach, you know?
I don't know.
- [Mark] It's almost like what you need
is a new childhood.
- Yeah, I wish I could go back.
If I could go to sleep and
just, like, dream it,
I'd feel better.
A dream!
If I could go to sleep
and dream my childhood.
It's just the whole time dreaming, like.
Just dream it and wake up, I'd be happy.
I don't know what it is to be a child.
- [Mark] But then you wake up
and you're living on the street
and people are treating you badly.
- I don't know what it is to go skating,
I don't know to go no sleepovers.
I don't know how it is to
play with no Barbie dolls.
I don't know how to hopscotch.
I don't know how to ride a bike.
I don't even ride a bike.
(indistinguishable speech)
I swear to God.
A little bit.
A little bit, struggle.
But, I don't know how to ride a bike.
I don't know how to skate.
I don't know how to swim.
I'd drown. I'd be dead.
- [Mark] You drive a car?
- A little bit.
I ain't gonna lie.
I don't know how to do nothin'
I'm supposed to know how to do.
All I know is how to fuck and suck.
That's it.
That's all.
I'm good at that.
That's it.
I'm good at it.
I pass the test on that.
But, anything else, I
don't know a thing at all.
I don't know how to-
I know how to cook, I cook.
Oh, yeah!
I cook my ass off.
Homemade gravy, that part, yeah!
But, anything else?
My grandma taught me how to cook.
Comb hair? Look at my hair.
Do I know how to comb hair?
No, I don't know how to do my hair.
I don't know to do shit.
Nothin'.
There's not one thing that
I know how to do for man.
For anybody.
I don't know how to do kids.
I don't know how to do shit
because I wasn't taught how to do it.
So, I don't know something
I wasn't taught how to do.
You know?
Suckin' and fuckin' for
money is all I know.
He touches you, you get money from him.
That's all I know.
I don't know how to do no hopscotch,
no handball,
no shit that a girl supposed to do
when she's growing up.
No, no, um-
I don't know nothing.
Just suck and fuck.
That's it.
That's all. And recycle.
That's it. That's all.
People don't understand.
I had a hard life.
No, they didn't.
My life is hard.
They had their parents growing up.
They had a house growing up.
I didn't have shit growing up.
But, a hard time.
People should appreciate what they had
because I didn't have shit.
- [Mark] Your parents,
almost, were enemies.
- My parents hated me, you know?
I don't know.
I don't care, man.
My mom hated me because my
dad and her are first cousins.
That all wasn't my problem.
I didn't ask any more
and I knew that.
It had nothin' to do
with y'all being cousins.
It had nothin' to do with ya'll being
fucked up with the family.
In Louisiana, we were fuckin' all these,
ya'll incest.
And ya'll knew that.
They had no problem.
They didn't knew me.
I didn't ask to be born.
Why should you take it out on me for?
You know? It ain't my problem.
It's not my fuckin' problem.
- [Mark] Do you have
hope of your life ever
becoming peaceful and happy again?
- [Latoya] Yeah, but...
Yeah, I have hope but...
Yeah, it won't, it won't.
Because, I'll always have
memories of stupid shit
happening to me and I
won't make nobody happy
because I went through all my life
and I didn't know how to treat nobody.
So, I'll be a loner.
Always.
I know I am,
because I don't know how to treat nobody.
I don't know how to treat no
fuckin' body that's nice to me.
I met guys.
I've met a lot, a lot, a lot of nice guys
that take care of me,
but I don't know how to
treat the motherfuckers,
so they leave.
See, I don't know how to
treat nobody, you understand?
I don't treat nobody good.
I only treat them bad.
- [Mark] You can't accept it.
- [Latoya] I don't know
how to treat nobody.
Like I said,
it's hard for me to accept
somebody who's good to me
because I've been treated so fuckin' bad
all my life.
You know?
It's hard for me to accept that.
I wanna ask my mom, you know,
"Why?"
You know?
I ask why and she say,
"None of your damn business, bitch."
"I'm your mom. Don't question me."
What?
Well, why you treat me so bad?
She would talk shit to me.
"Fuck you."
To this day, she talk to
me like that, you know?
"Why aren't you dead?"
Call me a bitch in front of my son
right in front of his face.
What you do that for?
'Cause my dad was your cousin?
It ain't my fault.
Get over it.
You're grown.
Get over it, mom.
You're older.
You don't do that to me.
She'd be like,
she'd treat them like a queen and king,
my brother and them.
Give me shoes from the thrift shop.
They get shoes from the Shoe Warehouse
or Payless Shoes.
Give me shoes, clothes
from the thrift shop.
Give them clothes from the mall.
That ain't right.
(Latoya sniffs)
I gotta wear hand me down shoes
and they get new shoes.
That ain't right. That ain't right.
They're rushing me to pick my shoes out
and they get to take their time.
We're rushing me to get my stuff
and they get to run
around and shop around.
All that.
That ain't fair, man.
We all came out her same pussy
and she treat me like shit.
She didn't wanna have me.
My grandma made her have me.
My mom was not gonna have me.
My grandmother made her have me.
My grandmother, she
didn't believe in abortion
so my grandma made her have me
at fifteen years old.
- [Mark] Latoya, do you believe in God?
- No, not really.
- [Mark] 'Cause when I
listen to your story.
- [Latoya] Not really, no, not really.
- [Mark] It's hard for me to believe.
- [Latoya] I don't, I don't, I don't
because... because... because...
(Latoya cries)
Why would God let this happen to me?
Why would God let my mom do me like that?
Why do God allow a child go through that?
Do I believe in God?
No, I don't fuckin' believe in God.
No, no, no, I don't believe in God.
Fuck that. Fuck God.
I don't believe in fuck.
I don't believe in no goddamn God.
What kind of God would let a
child go through this shit?
Allow a child to be molested,
raped, fingered in the butt?
A kid!
God would not allow-
Oh, fuck that!
No, I don't believe in God.
Okay, I don't care what nobody say.
No, I don't.
God would not allow this
to happen to a child,
if there was a God.
I don't believe in nothing I can't see.
No, I don't believe in God.
(indistinguishable speech)
I don't believe in God.
No, I don't, I don't, I don't!
That's it.
I'm through.
I'm done. I'm done.
I don't wanna-
I'm done.
(Latoya crying)
This is crazy, man.
It don't make no sense.
I don't understand.
I don't get it.
I don't know why.
I just, I just want an answer.
I can't get an answer from nobody.
(Latoya blowing her nose)
I want an answer.
Why, though, why?
Why me? What did I do wrong?
I didn't ask to be born.
(sirens and horn blowing)
I didn't ask my mama to have me.
I didn't ask her to be fuckin' each other
while their cousins, related.
Ain't my problem.
I don't, I don't, I don't-
You know, I went to school.
I did everything I had to do.
I went- I even struggled in school,
but I did, I finished-
I graduated high school.
I struggled and I finished school.
You know, I got a lot of talent.
I know how to draw,
I know how to sing,
dance, I can cook.
I got a lot of talent, but...
I'm a good artist.
I draw good. Draw?
Can't nobody beat me drawing.
Can't nobody beat me drawing. Nobody.
I draw good. I draw pencil.
Can't nobody beat me drawing.
Nobody beat me drawing.
I don't care what anybody say.
I do... You'll see.
- [Mark] Draw me something.
- Right now?
- [Mark] No, not now.
- Yeah, yeah, I'll draw something.
I'll draw something.
I need a- I need a sketch pad.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'll get
you one. I'll set it up.
- ...and a marker.
That's it.
I know how to draw.
I draw the cartoon
characters. Stewie, like?
Stewie, from Family Guy.
And SpongeBob SquarePants.
I like cartoons, you know?
All I have on my phone are cartoons.
YouTube cartoons, cartoons, cartoons.
Woody Woodpecker.
They make me happy.
Like a kid. I'm a little kid.
- [Mark] Those are your good memories?
- I'm a little kid. Yeah.
- [Mark] What were your
favorite memories as a kid?
- Oh, um...
It's a shame, it's a shame
I got to think about it.
See, it's a shame it takes
so long to think about it.
We had my mom take us to Chucky Cheese.
My mom, she would take
us to Chucky Cheese.
We all didn't want to go,
but Mom would say, "Let's go".
Chucky Cheese. Swimming.
I don't know how to swim.
To the, god...
Rollercoaster, you know?
My mom would take us to a lot of places,
but it wasn't fun I would have.
Come in the house early,
we'd make mud pies.
You know? Little kids.
Anyway, Mark... I'm done.
- [Mark] All right, gal. Thank
you so much for coming in.